und jetzt das heute journal
schönen guten Abend gestritten wurde in
letzter Zeit jede Menge nicht nur in der
Ampel auch innerhalb der Grünen asyl-
und heizungskompromiss hatten die
Gemüter erhitzt und so war die
Befürchtung groß dass es heute auf dem
kleinen Parteitag der Grünen
hochhergehen würde aber der Appell des
Parteichefs nuripur man müsse
geschlossen aus dem innerparteilichen
Streit hervorgehen scheint am Ende
gehört worden zu sein erst einmal
Andreas
wie sehr die letzten eineinhalb Jahre
die Grünen in der Regierung geprägt
haben lässt sich vor allem an ihm
ablesen Robert Habeck ist wochenlang für
sein heizungsgesetz verbal verprügelt
worden jetzt steht ein aus grünen Sicht
aufgeweicht der Entwurf durchhalte
Parolen vom Vizekanzler an die Basis hat
keine Sehnsucht
Opposition das wäre Versagen von der
historischen Aufgabe die uns gegeben ist
es wird keine einfachen Lösung geben es
wird auch nie mehr einfach gehen der
Wind wird immer von vorne Wehnen es ist
ein werben um Zustimmung ein werben für
das grüne Spitzenpersonal in
Regierungsverantwortung ein werben um
Verständnis das Regieren und Opposition
zwei Paar politische Schuhe sind Länder
Rad in Bad Vilbel eigentlich sollte der
Ausflug in die hessische Provinz den
Landesgrünen Rückenwind und
Unterstützung für die Wahl im Herbst
geben doch schon die Demonstranten vor
der Halle machen klar heute geht es hier
vorrangig um ein urgrünes
identitätsthema es geht um Asyl und
Menschenrechtspolitik
schmerzt mich dass es keine
verpflichtenden
verteilungsmechanismen gibt es schmerzt
mich dass diese Entscheidung auch einen
asylrechtsverschärfung für Deutschland
in der Konsequenz bedeutet es ist nicht
tragbar das Kinder und Jugendliche an
Außengrenzen inhaftiert werden
das ist nicht die Humanität die unserer
südpolitik braucht vor allem die
grenzverfahren bei denen auch Familien
mit Kindern in streng gesicherten Lagern
interniert werden dürfen sorgen für
Unmut die grüne Außenministerin hatte
dem zugestimmt rechtfertigt dass ohne
deutsches Jahr hier keine Einigung über
eine gerechte Verteilung von
Flüchtlingen wenn wir haushaltsbündnis
90 die Grünen nicht dieser Zumutung
stellen dann werden andere
Entscheidungen fällen dann hätten die
Feinde Europas und Menschenrechte Feinde
der Menschenrechte gewonnen Partei linke
und die Grüne Jugend laufen gegen bärbox
Zustimmung Sturm und so beschließt am
Ende der Länderrat einstimmig die
Außenministerin solle sich jetzt noch
einmal auf europäischer Ebene dafür
einsetzen die grenzverfahren zu
entschärfen wir werden jetzt alles dafür
tun dass es eben diese Verbesserung gibt
weil es darf eben nicht ein bisschen
weniger also rechts Verschärfung geben
sondern es braucht eine deutliche
Verbesserung der humanitären Lage an den
Außengrenzen insofern haben wir das
erreicht was wir wollten nämlich unsere
inhaltliche Position klargestellt aber
auch klargestellt wo wir noch
Verbesserungen anstreben vor allen
Dingen aber dass wir dieses gemeinsam
tun und nicht anderen den Gefallen tun
im Vorfeld der Landtagswahlen von Hessen
und Bayern und
medienwirksam zu zerlegen am Ende steht
ein Beschluss bei dem sich alle wieder
lieb haben doch der Partei interne
Streit über die Asylpolitik ist
allerdings nur aufgeschoben beigelegt
ist der sicher nicht
die Stimmung intern etwas angespannt die
Zustimmung im aktuellen Politbarometer
liegt für die Grünen bei nur 16% 2%
Punkte hinter der AFD also was ist los
in der Partei fragen wie die Partei
Chefin Ricarda lang schönen guten Abend
hallo guten Abend es gab im Vorfeld viel
Theater um den Asylkompromiss auch um
den Kompromiss in Sachen Heizung und Co
heute bei Ihnen auf dem Parteitag was
relativ gemäßigt wie viel Arbeit hat sie
das gekostet dass es heute auf der Bühne
nicht knallt
ich habe natürlich in den letzten Tagen
schon auch meinen Job gemacht und da
einige Arbeit reingesteckt aber ich
glaube am Ende muss man auch sagen
vieles was man gelesen hat die letzten
Tage unsere Partei alte Kämpfe brechen
wieder aus oder Flüge Krieg davon habe
ich heute auf der Bühne und auf dem
ganzen Länderrat überhaupt gar nichts
gesehen sondern wir haben eine Partei
gesehen die nicht anhand von Schablonen
diskutiert sind sich sehr ernsthaft
inhaltlich mit wichtigen Themen
auseinandersetzt klimaneutralen
Wohlstand aber natürlich auch der Frage
wie Menschen umgehen die Schutz hier in
Europa suchen und die am Ende aber auch
immer wieder klar gemacht hat wir gehen
jetzt nicht zurück in die Nische sondern
wir wollen weiter Verantwortung tragen
und machen Politik für die Realität die
da ist kämpfen aber auch für Mehrheiten
um sie zu verändern es gab in letzter
Zeit viel Streit auf offener Bühne das
hat weder Ihnen noch den Ampel Partner
wirklich genutzt und Sie haben immer
wieder gesagt sie sind eine Partei die
auch Kompromisse sucht jetzt bei den
Sektor Zielen die haben sie aufgegeben
kein Tempolimit dafür Autobahn Neuausbau
mit dem Kompromiss in Sachen geeg haben
sie die Klimaziele aufge wie viel
Kompromiss kann man machen bis man sich
selbst quasi auflöst oder seine Werte
über Bord wirft
ich würde vielleicht genau mal andersrum
aufzäumen wir haben uns diese Woche
darauf geeinigt dass das Gebäude
Energiegesetz noch bis zum Sommer kommt
also wir riesige Sprünge bei den
Einsparungen von CO2 im Gebäudesektor
machen ein Bereich der bisher vollkommen
außen vor war wir haben uns darauf
geeinigt dass die Lkw-Maut erhöht wird
und das Geld was dort eingenommen wird
nicht in die Straße fließt wie sonst
immer so ein in die Schiene in Ausbau
der Bahn fließt wir haben europaweit das
Ende des fossilen Verbrenners
beschlossen die erneuerbaren Energien so
schnell ausgebaut wie ist die ganzen
letzten Jahre davor noch nicht mal in
unserem grünen Wahlprogramm vorstellbar
war haben dort wirklich ein Turbo
reingehauen man kann ganz klar sagen so
viel Klimaschutz für den letzten
anderthalb Jahren gab es in diesem Land
noch aber da würden die Kritiker sagen
das Reden Sie sich jetzt auch ein
bisschen schön gerade in Sachen
Klimaschutz und da muss man wenn man
über das Gebäude Energiegesetz spricht
schon auch fragen warum eigentlich sind
sie nicht vorher auf diese logische wie
simple Idee gekommen zu sagen erst die
Kommunen und dann die Besitzer und Co
warum mussten sie quasi von der FDP
dahin gebracht werden dass sie erst
Schritt 1 und dann Schritt zwei machen
die Sachen wurden ja immer schon
parallel miteinander verhandelt und wir
haben auch schon vor ein paar Wochen
gesagt lassen doch zusammensetzen
schauen wie wir es miteinander
verhandeln ich war froh dass jetzt auch
die Koalitionspartner in der letzten
Woche endlich dazu bereit waren aber von
da hat man die Idee können Sie doch auf
die Idee können Sie doch selber kommen
dass man es doch ist doch logisch dass
man erst die Kommunen quasi dazu bringen
muss den ersten Schritt zu machen und
dann alle anderen damit Sie wissen wo
sie dran sind
ich finde sie auch eine gute Idee und
wie gesagt natürlich gab es auch bei uns
Überlegung ob man diese Richtung geht
und musste nur erstmal ins verhandeln
kommen dann zu sagen was macht da
eigentlich Sinn das Gesetz zu kommunalen
wärmeplanung oder die Planung dazu die
kommen ja nicht aus nicht sondern es war
schon lange auch besprochen im
Wirtschaftsministerium im Bauministerium
jetzt zu sagen das Synchronisieren das
finde ich eine gute Lösung und dann muss
ich am Ende auch nicht sagen wer hat
sich dann ticken mehr oder ein Ticken
weniger durchgesetzt sondern ist doch
gut dass wir das Gesetz des
praxistaugliche machen dass wir
schrittweise machen das wäre aber auch
und das war für mich immer der wichtige
Punkt dass das nicht verloren geht das
klares Signal setzen die Zeit von neuen
Öl und Gasheizung die ist jetzt vorbei
aus Klimaschutzgründen aber
sozial durchdacht ist das ganze ja auch
immer noch nicht Förderung ausnahmen
sind noch ungeklärt warum haben sie das
nicht von Anfang an mit gedacht
das wäre tatsächlich was was ich aus der
Debatte mitnehmen ich habe gerade gesagt
dass für mich auch eine
verbraucherschutzdebatte wir hätten es
vielleicht auch früher so führen sollen
also darüber sprechen was für kosten
eigentlich auf Menschen zukommen die ich
neue gassenöl Heizung einbauen aber und
das stimmt das kann man zu viel machen
wie man es will wenn am Ende die
Menschen nicht das Geld haben um sich
zum Beispiel Wärmepumpe einbauen dann
hilft das auch wenig dann schwindet die
Akzeptanz und das heißt das wäre für
mich sowohl jetzt der Auftrag für die
parlamentarischen Verhandlung die noch
anstehen dass wir dazu einem sozialen
Ausgleich kommen der gestaffelt ist also
wer mehr Geld hat weniger wer wenig Geld
hat kriegt richtig richtig viel und das
ist glaube ich eine Aufgabe dass die
soziale Frage immer am Anfang stehen
muss wenn wir bei der sozialen Frage
sind kommen wir auch zum Thema Werte und
zum Asyl Kompromiss da haben die Grünen
heute auf ihrem Partei Tag den zumindest
mal nicht abgelehnt sie sagen da muss
noch ein bisschen nachverhandelt werden
sicherlich was das Thema Kinder und
Frauen und Familien anbelangt die ja bis
zur asylprüfung so ist es aktuell
erstmal festgehalten auch interniert
werden sollen können Sie das wirklich so
vertreten oder sagen Sie wenn das nicht
durchkommt dann kann Deutschland nicht
zustimmen
wir haben heute noch mal klar Positionen
bezogen zu der Einigung die es schon im
EU innenministerrat gab die einfach mit
substanziellen asylrechtsverschärfung
einhergeht wo wir ganz klar gesagt haben
dass die natürlich für uns als Partei
eigentlich so nicht tragbar sind und wir
haben klare Ziele formuliert für die
Verhandlung die jetzt noch anstehenden
sogenannten Trilog also zwischen
Europäischen Parlament dem Rat und der
Kommission und ein Ziel das haben sie
schon genannt ist ganz klar dass Kinder
und Familien aus dem grenzverfahren
ausgenommen werden aber auch zum
Beispiel eine noch verbindlichere
Verteilung und am Ende und das haben wir
heute auch gesagt werden wir uns als
Partei das Ergebnis anschauen
was nennt sie Feser gesagt hat und das
werden sie wissen die Innenministerin
hat gesagt wenn Kommission Rat und
Parlament zusammenkommen und dabei
bleiben dass Kinder Frauen Familien
interniert werden wird sie für
Deutschland dafür stimmen
naja wir sind ja in eine Koalition in
einer Koalition verhandelt man auch mal
miteinander und wir haben ganz klar
gesagt wir werden uns das Ergebnis
gemeinsam anschauen wir werden aber auch
darauf schauen ob es Verbesserungen gibt
und am Ende natürlich ob es unterm
Strich eine Verbesserung im Asylrecht
bedeutet und eine Verbesserung für
Europa mitgehen
ich habe mir gerade schon gesagt dass
wir uns diese Ergebnis anschauen müssen
das ist ein sehr komplexes Bereich das
sind verschiedenste recht so Schätzung
das sind verschiedene Rechtsakte und am
Ende werden wir die Positionierung auch
zu den jeweiligen Rechtsakten davon
abhängig machen ob es unterm Strich das
bringt es nichts einfach nur den einen
Punkt zu benennen zu sagen nur daran
machen wir es abhängig sondern unterm
Strich gibt es eine Verbesserung
Asylrecht gibt es eine Verbesserung von
Europa und ich finde es gut dass wir als
Partei hier nicht einfach schon mal den
blanko-check ausstellen aber auch und
von Leuten die jetzt verhandeln im
Europäischen Parlament die Freiheit
geben da wirklich das Beste rauszuholen
und am Ende und ich glaube das haben wir
heute gezeigt auch eine schwierige
Debatte über ein Ergebnis einsteigen
sagt Ricarda lang vom kleinen Partei Tag
der Grünen die Chefin der Grünen war das
vielen herzlichen Dank für Ihre Zeit und
fürs Gespräch
danke ihnen schönen Abend noch
welches wir aufgezeichnet haben und
Gundula deine Nachrichten beginnen auch
mit einem kleinen Tag die CDU hat auf
einem Konvent an Ihrem neuen
Grundsatzprogramm gearbeitet dabei
warnte Partei Chef März davor heikle
Themen aus Sorge vor einem Vergleich mit
der AFD nicht anzusprechen diskutiert
wurde über Pläne für eine große
Steuerreform oder ein soziales
Pflichtjahr Beschlüsse gab es nicht im
nächsten Mai soll das neue
Parteiprogramm verabschiedet werden
zum 70 Jahrestag des Volksaufstandes in
der DDR ist in vielen Städten der Opfer
gedacht worden mindestens 55 Menschen
starben als die sowjetische Armee 1953
die Proteste niederschlug bei der
zentralen Feier in Berlin erklärte
Bundeskanzler Scholz den Volksaufstand
vom 17 Juni 1953 zu einem der
wichtigsten und stolzesten Ereignisse in
der freiheitsgeschichte unseres Landes
in Uganda haben mutmaßlich islamistische
Rebellen eine Schule angegriffen
mindestens 41 Menschen getötet und
mehrere entführt die meisten Opfer
Schulkinder unmittelbar nach dem
Überfall hat die ugandische Armee die
Verfolgung aufgenommen auch UNICEF
forderte die sofortige Freilassung
mehrere afrikanische Regierungschefs
haben Russland zu Verhandlungen mit der
Ukraine aufgerufen der Krieg müsse enden
aber gestern hatte schon der ukrainische
Präsident selenski Verhandlungen zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt
abgelehntämische Putin zeigte sich zwar
offen für einen konstruktiven Dialog wie
er sagte aber nur bei Anerkennung der
Annexion von fünf ukrainischen Regionen
heute startet die größte
multisportveranstaltung in Deutschland
seit den Olympischen Spielen 1972 die
Special Olympics World Games jahrelang
haben 7000 Frauen und Männer aus 190
Ländern daraufhin trainiert jahrelang
liefen auch die Vorbereitungen auf
dieses Groß-Event für Menschen mit
geistigen Beeinträchtigung Nils Carmen
die Bühne könnte nicht größer sein für
ein Sport Ereignis dessen Helden heute
noch keiner kennt es sind nicht die
Zahlen allein die beeindrucken es geht
vor allem um Respekt für Menschen mit
Beeinträchtigungen
deswegen freue ich mich dass hier die
ganze Welt in Berlin noch mehr
zusammenkommt und gerade auch eine
Gruppe die man sonst nicht so beachtet
nämlich geistig Behinderte und dann noch
welche die ganz tolle Leistung
hoffentlich bringen werden 50.000
Zuschauer im fast voll Olympiastadion
darunter auch der erste Mann im starte
Bundespräsident Frankreich der
Steinmeier und ein paar rein weiter an
diesem strahlenden Sommerabend der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
die Special Olympics sind die weltweit
größte inklusive Sportveranstaltung
natürlich gibt es auch eine Fackel mit
dem in Griechenland entzündeten Feuer
genau wie bei den Olympischen Spielen
dieses Feuer ist heute quer durch Berlin
und Olympiastadion getragen worden und
hat dabei viele Berliner auf diese
Spieler aufmerksam gemacht
Special Olympics hat mir davor
eigentlich gar nicht so viel gesagt
Paralympics war mir klar ein Begriff
aber Special Olympics noch gar nicht so
doll und ich bin eigentlich als volunt
hier jetzt hier der wesentliche
Unterschied zu den Paralympics den
Spielen der körperlich gehandicapten
sind hier Menschen mit geistigen
Beeinträchtigungen am Start mehr als 400
aus Deutschland sie alle Vertrauen auf
die verbindende Kraft des Sports
trainieren und Erfolge feiern diese
Chance sollten alle Menschen haben
ich bin auf jeden Fall sehr aufgeregt
weil ich hatte noch nie so eine große
Veranstaltung zum ersten Mal voll hier
im Berliner Olympiastadion insgesamt
stehen 26 Sportarten auf dem Programm
Menschen mit Handicap sollen vom Rand
zurück in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
zusammen und schlagbar so heißt der
Treffen des Logan der Spieler und du
Medaillen geht's natürlich auch was ist
das größte auf was du dich freust in den
kommenden Tagen wenn vielleicht eine
goldmerei oder eine silbern daher einige
Wettbewerbe haben schon vor der
Eröffnung angefangen los geht's immer
mit der Klassifizierung damit zum
Beispiel in der Rhythmischen
Sportgymnastik Athletinnen mit
vergleichbaren Beeinträchtigungen
gegeneinander antreten es ist das erste
Mal dass dieses Special Olympics World
Games in Deutschland stattfinden
es gibt diese spiele seit 1968 alle zwei
Jahre kämpfen ganz besondere Menschen
nicht nur um Gold Silber und Bronze in
den kommenden neuen Tagen geht es vor
allem um die Anerkennung die alle
gleichermaßen verdienen
eigentlich hat der neue britische König
Charles im November Geburtstag aber wie
schon bei seiner Mutter findet die
Militärparade zu seinen Ehren im Juni
statt bei bestem Wetter führte der
Monarch unter der traditionellen
bärenfällen Mütze mehr als 1000 Soldaten
Reiter und Musiker an im Gefolge die
königliche Familie danach König Charles
erleichtert auf dem Balkon des
Buckingham Palace
[Musik]
und hier wie jeden Samstag die
gewinnzahlen vom Lotto sie lauten ohne
gewährt zwei 15 19 22 32 43 Superzahl 4
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite 556
an der Förde wurde bei Bilderbuchwetter
die Kieler Woche eröffnet so sommerlich
sonnig bleibt das Wetter allerdings
nicht im Nordosten später auch im Westen
mehr Wolken vereinzelt Schauer 23 Grad
auf Rügen und 33 Grad am Oberrhein in
den nächsten Tagen zunehmend Schauer und
Gewitter Lokal auch Unwetter mit
Starkregen und Sturmböen schwül warm
wird es bei 24 bis 32 Grad
das war's ein schönen Sonntag und bis
morgen ihr folgt jetzt die Filmnacht im
ZDF Fast and Furious 8 und wir sagen
tschüss und gehen fast nach Hause ohne
furious machen sie es gut
[Musik]